we are both featured in this amazing new
video game death
stranding yeah you are you are really
the star of deaths training and then I
just happened to be shooting some stuff
for this show in Tokyo when I got to
meet the creator of the game and he
thought it would be really fun to put me
in the game so we'll put the
side-by-sides up there there's me when
there's me yeah
and and you know your your character the
game is visually absolutely stunning and
I'm saying this I have no I'm in there
as kind of a joke and clearly and so I
have no I have no interest in the game
financial or anything I just was blown
away by the imagination that went into
that it's it's so visually original and
stunning yeah you know it started a
camera del Toro called me and he goes
there's a guy named Hideo who's gonna
call you just say yes right and I was
like who is he just does not matter just
say yes and then he also came there's a
lot of san diego in this but he also
came to San Diego with an iPad and was
showing me the things he was working on
and I just said yes right off the bat
yeah as you were told just say yeah yeah
I mean get one give me my first movie so
I do everything Guillermo tells me to do
but but yeah you know we do these little
things like I'd be sitting there and I'd
be waiting and I would just kind of do
like this waiting and he'd go roll
cameras do that again and I was like and
then I'd sit there and I'd go like this
waiting you know cuz there's a whole
team of people and you know you go do
that again and I was like what is he
doing and he explained to me when when
people play the game is about connecting
right right and so when people play that
game in the dark they want to relate to
the character like really relate to the
character so there's so much Norman isms
in that game really is you it really is
ways yeah there are some differences
your character has some very interesting
weapons yeah my P is a weapon yeah and
you're here your urine is a weapon yeah
my poop is the weapon - yeah can I say
poop yeah can I say yeah not on
Nickelodeon but pretty much everywhere
yeah yeah how was your how is that a
weapon how is it turns into a grenade oh
yeah okay all right I know it's my
endorsement of this game yeah but you
know it's it's funny cuz like the
character is he's so closed off and he'd
he'd just like leave me alone and he
doesn't want to touch people and slowly
as you play the game you start to feel
yourself open up as the character opens
up which is very much Daryl Dixon yep
you know it's my run of that show